qui n'a jamais cédé au piège du
marketing même si on essaie de faire des
choix éclairés au fil des prochaines
semaines je vous présente une série de
trois reportages pour vous aider garder
la tête froide lorsque vous faites
l'épicerie cette semaine qu'est-ce qui
se cache derrière l'écran de fumée des
emballages
[Musique]
ne tombez pas dans les pièges du
marketing
pour vous aider l'épicerie lève le voile
sur certaines techniques utilisées par
l'industrie pour vous vendre ses
produits aujourd'hui le marketing sur
les emballages
ne détournez pas votre attention de ce
qui est important parfois il y a des
mots clés sur les emballages qui
détournent notre attention de ce qui
devrait être plus important pour nous
c'est une tactique qui est souvent
utilisée en alimentation d'attirer notre
attention sur quelque chose de très
spécifique pour moins qu'on se rende
compte qu'on se préoccupe d'autres
choses un exemple qui me frappe vraiment
en ce moment c'est la légation ou la
mention sans colorant n'y arômes
artificiel elle est sur énormément de
produits et notamment sur presque tous
les pains tranchés qui lorsqu'il choisit
un pain
Satan à ce qu'il y ait des colorants ou
des arômes naturels ou artificiels dans
du pain tranché personne ce n'est pas un
argument de base qui devrait nous servir
à nous aider à faire un bon choix on
veut regarder ce qu'il y a des grains ou
des farines entières est-ce que des
fibres est-ce que la teneur en sodium
est raisonnable ça c'est ce qui nous
intéresse quand on achète un pain
tranché mais colorant artificiel en 12
et moi si on a besoin beaucoup moins de
médecine dans un pain tranché mieux vous
retournez à l'école de boulangerie ça
s'applique à beaucoup d'autres produits
à l'épicerie vous cet argument là est
utilisé oui pour nous rassurer mais au
final est-ce une réelle valeur ajoutée
bien souvent la réponse est non
autre tactique utilisée par les
compagnies les éditions limitées on voit
beaucoup ça dans les céréales à la
déjeuner dans les croustilles les
chocolats instinctivement on se trouve à
faire tomber notre jugement critique
qu'on aurait normalement pour cette
catégorie là
[Musique]
dans les éditions limitées on voit
souvent des associations avec par
exemple des films pour enfants ce que
c'est un peu ça aussi qui nous détourne
mais oui effectivement le fait de se
servir d'un personnage c'est sûr que
c'est une accroche très très efficace
ne tombez pas dans le panneau des mots
tendances les exemples les plus
flagrants qu'on a vu récemment sans
gluten ça fait déjà quelques années qui
les apparu on envoyait presque pas
c'était juste des produits de spécialité
et tout d'un coup les mots sans gluten
se sont retrouvés sur à peu près tout et
n'importe quoi il y a des musiques qui
nous ramènent au bon vieux plan maison
je pense à vrai authentique ou style
artisanal trois mots qui réfèrent soit à
la méthode de fabrication ou à la
composition du produit
qui ont pour objectif en fait de nous
donner une impression positive sur la
qualité du produit quand on m'indique
par exemple sur une boîte de céréales à
déjeuner que ça contient des vrais
fruits en quoi est-ce que le mot vrai
m'ajoute c'est quoi des faux fruits
il faut aussi se méfier de l'appellation
style artisanal parce qu'il faut savoir
que le mot artisanal est réglementé on
ne peut pas l'utiliser juste parce que
ça nous plaît ça doit s'appliquer à une
entreprise de petite taille qui fabrique
en petits lots et avec des méthodes les
plus manuelles possible ou du moins avec
des équipements et des ingrédients le
plus proche possible de ce que serait en
le faisant à la maison beaucoup de très
grands joueurs vont avoir lancé les
produits et des marques qui vont avoir
cette mention là de style artisanal pour
nous rassurer soi-disant sur la qualité
mais c'est fait avec les mêmes
équipements que le reste de la gamme sur
lequel ce n'est pas mentionné
méfiez-vous de l'effet de Halo
l'effet de Halo en bref c'est une erreur
de perception on se laisse happer par un
seul élément d'un produit et on oublie
le reste
un exemple très simple c'est celui des
légumes tout le monde sait que les
légumes c'est bon pour la santé alors
quand une entreprise indique sur un
emballage la présence de légumes que ce
soit en saveur ou présence comme
ingrédient ça peut créer un effet de
halo donc nous donner l'impression que
l'ensemble de l'aliment est bon pour la
santé sur la simple fait qu'il y ait des
légumes à l'intérieur des chips aux
légumes
c'est un des meilleurs exemples la
plupart du temps c'est un peu de poudre
de légumes dedans mais le légume est
loin en titi donc c'est pas plus santé
une autre façon que plusieurs marques
vont se servir de l'effet de Halo c'est
via le nom de la marque c'est sûr que
quand on appelle un gamme de produits
helty choice ça me suggère très très
fort que c'est un choix santé ou du
moins meilleur pour la santé mais là où
ça devient piège c'est lorsque cette
interprétation là elle est véritablement
erronée fait que la seule façon de le
savoir c'est de jeter un petit coup
d'œil rapide à la liste des ingrédients
pour savoir si cette attribut-là qu'on
met de l'avant est-il bel et bien
présent en quantité suffisante pour que
ça vaille la peine d'en parler
ne vous laissez pas berner par certains
logos il y a aussi des logos qui parfois
nous rassurent dans nos achats
absolument il y a plusieurs grands
joueurs grands transformateurs
alimentaires qui ont développé leur
propre programme ou leur propre logo
pour nous indiquer des changements ou
des améliorations dans leurs produits je
pense entre autres à des sur plusieurs
de ces biscuits ou craquelins qui a la
mention meilleur choix meilleur choix
que quoi c'est la bonne question à se
poser exactement ce soit ça que ce soit
des mentions comme sucré sensé sur
certaines céréales de kelog qui est
apparu plus récemment tous ces logos
sont créés de toutes pièces l'entreprise
donc ils ont eux-mêmes déterminé leur
critères et ces critères et ses
paramètres là doivent être rendus
publics évidemment mais ils ne sont pas
toujours clairement indiqués sur
l'emballage il y a des logos aussi qui
font référence à nos valeurs par exemple
durable qui viennent pas nécessairement
d'une entreprise certifiée parfaitement
raison et on envoie de plus en plus
appareils il y a quand même certains de
ces logos là qui sont des certifications
officielles un coup d’œil rapide sur
Internet vous allez le voir tout de
suite si vous tombez sur le site d'un
organisme indépendant vous savez que ça
a été certifié par une tierce partie
dans d'autres cas c'est une initiative
directe de l'entreprise ou du détaillant
ça ne veut pas dire que c'est pas
intéressant faut juste savoir de quoi il
retourne exactement donc avant de mettre
un produit dans notre panier on a des
petits devoirs à faire mais on dirait
que c'est c'est normal d'être
séduit par des emballages je vais
surtout pas qu'on se culpabilise de se
laisser séduire par un emballage un
emballage sert à ça attirer notre
attention les entreprises ne sont pas
mal intentionnées non plus dans ce
qu'elles font mais elles sont elles sont
en guerre la concurrence est énorme
alors faut juste être conscient de ça et
se permettre de se faire notre avocat du
diable lorsque ça semble trop beau pour
être vrai ou c'est juste pas clair
tourner l'emballage la liste
d'ingrédients nous dit beaucoup de
choses en lien avec ces allégations là
jette un petit coup d'oeil rapide vous
allez facilement et rapidement
développer des réflexes ça va devenir
une seconde nature